the total prize money accumulated so far
is now 34.8 billion won
running on the stairs if these people
aren't careful someone's gonna get hurt
good thing this machine came with the
push the button twice and it will delete
exactly the selection you were thinking
software installed very convenient thank
you thank you for what how am i supposed
to know anything about what's going on
without a previously on segment you
saved me
thank you number one for this graphic
reminder of the events of the last
episode just as my eyeballs had finally
healed from all the acid i had to pour
on them after watching it for myself
thanks a bunch i'm sorry
i was wrong to suggest separating i
don't say that
how could you know what it was one of
the reasons this show grinds my gears is
that i honestly have no idea whether
gihan knows exactly what's going on or
is completely freaking oblivious or is
just outright dumb i really want to root
for the guy i really do i just wish he
wasn't so pathetic once again this
episode persists in piggy banking on for
all of the money grabbing some time the
total prize money accumulated so far is
now 34.8 billion won show manages to
predict the total number of sin juan it
will get by the end of the season wait
do they not get socks this just seems
like a recipe for foot fungus and all
sorts of unpleasant odors come to think
of it the show doesn't really indicate
if the players have multiple outfits or
if there's a wash day and honestly what
are we even watching for if we aren't
going to explore laundry protocol
hard-boiled eggs would not be my first
choice as a prison manager largely due
to the huge cleanup job that would be
required now since the rest of the
episode isn't punctuated by the
crunching of 200 discarded eggshells
underfoot i'm assuming that somebody
eventually cleaned them all up which is
a huge waste of that somebody's time if
you're committed to eggs then just
de-shell them in the kitchen when will a
tv show do breakfast right when you're
branding their bottles with the shapes
logo what's the point of that did you
have them made up at your local place or
hit up discountdeathmugs.com
i mean if you're looking for marketing
opportunities maybe start with the
jumpsuits
and the directors said well they're all
out apples so let's have the character
break an egg on his forehead after
assuming it's hard-boiled so the
audience truly knows he's making an
[ __ ] out of you and um
ming why is 212 covering this side of
her mouth from being seen when as far as
we can see the only people who might see
her behind her shut your mouth and grab
an egg title of my sex tape this feels
like an extreme overreaction i mean doc
sue is shelling out a real beating here
and if he's not careful he'll crack a
rib and scramble this guy's poor organs
he really should stop before the yolk
goes too far unlike me the fuchsia suits
just let this beating lead to murder why
again up until now they've been very
clear about the integrity of the games
and yes they'll say they all planned it
later but we'll cross that glass bridge
when we come to it my point is if i was
one of the american vips and i lost a
bet on this kind of off the book i would
be furious i said if you just died
can't you hear me huh
help us now kihan is for some reason
still surprised by the baroness of the
field that should contain the [ __ ]
given by the people who run this place
this room apparently has cremation ovens
lined up on both sides must be hot as
hell in that room those ovens operated
1800 degrees each so at the very least
these guards should be sweating through
their fully enclosed rouge bodysuits
hurry it'll be bedtime too being a dick
about your undercover organ harvester's
bedtime we gotta keep an eye out it'll
be dangerous
and we'll come here if anything goes
down if they're that paranoid then why
are they even splitting up stay together
take a watch each at least then you'll
see the murder coming and have a chance
to make peace with your deity of choice
tonight if anything happens
we'll all meet in my bed right there
are you in lame orgy pickup lines listen
you don't trust people here because you
can
you do it because you don't have anybody
else this could be the worst damn advice
ever given in the history of television
an absence of options does not mean you
default to trusting whoever happens to
be in the room that's not how trust
works people by that logic they should
just go ahead and trust snakes on a pain
in the ass over here and sleep soundly
we gave you less food on purpose to make
you all fight each other first bullsh
there was less food because five people
took seconds sure the portions were
small but if no one cuts in line and no
one gets angry and no one happens to
beat someone to death and none of this
works out to your plan also even if this
is the case which i repeat it is not why
would all the workers know this this is
a triangle face i mean a square face
maybe but a freaking triangle face give
me a break okay last episode they hid
the note in the food because he was in
the middle of all the other players
which makes sense but why bother this
time around they have him performing
organ removals on a corpse in a secret
room and they're worried about passing a
[ __ ] note i'm a doctor out there
you might need me
so
you're gonna come give me a shot if i
get sick this show may well be doubling
down on making 212 as annoying as
humanly possible does she need to be
this stupid of course a doctor would be
a helpful addition to the team even if
this next challenge is a zero-sum game
of live or die she knows that they're
going to be starting a fight tonight so
what's the harm in keeping the doctor
until then are you getting any better
offers go sit somewhere in a corner come
lights out don't breathe or make a noise
if i hear you breathe
then i'll come for you turkey basters
[Music]
did that really require a [ __ ] jog
[Music]
this player must have known that she's
in very real danger after pointing the
finger at these guys earlier and yet she
just lays in her bed hoping it will all
blow over you know what they say
denial's not just a character on frasier
also i know i've mentioned it before but
this whole night of murder mini-game
makes zero of the sense as part of the
squid game it depends on random events
and is chaos in an otherwise ordered
environment someone got their purger
butter in my choco squid and i am not
having it also this darks on for all the
some time and then strobes on for all of
the even more amounts of all of the some
time
wow it was almost like they were taking
orders from the random old guy can you
imagine if that was the case of course
there's no way a show about violent
death games would be that nuanced with
its foreshadowing huh
shooting into the air is sin enough when
you're outside let alone inside where
did those bullets hit did they not
ricochet what if you hit the pig won't
anyone think of the pig when and why did
he install interior mask lighting hey
big guy is that a knife in your pocket
or are you just oh never mind
i love how after drag out melee
involving one knife a broken bottle and
a lot of fists and bunk beds everyone is
either completely fine or completely
dead there should be people with broken
limbs collapsed lungs concussions and
all sorts of various injuries look at
this wide shot i see at least 13 corpses
here many of which appeared to have died
instantly from stab wounds and later
they confirmed 27 kills there was one
knife and one broken bottle here in like
five minutes unless john wick snuck into
the room this is an impossible amount of
fatalities show has time to once again
show us how the geometry guards deal
with dead bodies this is the one part of
this that actually already made sense so
move it along people appreciate this
wide shot so i can compare a few numbers
here earlier you said there were 107
people left but there are at least 121
people still lit up on the board here
later you'll confirm the new postmaster
total is 80. but once these lights go
out you're only down to 95. so either
you've screwed up or you've got about 15
nameplates with lights stuck on that you
might want to get checked out got any
electricians in your shapely crew also
why are these numbers all out of order
murder all the people you want but i
will not stand for shoddy visual
organizational practices nobody here got
hurt so that's good disregarding
emotional trauma that's pretty neat
i'm not sure how well it fits wow the
rare patronize a woman by calling her
name pretty an insult a woman's
appearance line drive double down the
left field line that's gonna notch two
more sbis and it's only the top of the
fourth sitting but what's my
reward for guessing i'll go think about
it in the restroom okay
well that's escalated quickly previously
212 had to beg to go to the bathroom and
now they're both being allowed out for a
quick hide-the-squid game of their own
why is this even being allowed storing
your penis and your cigarettes in the
same location who exactly are these
one-word notes supposed to be helping
this seems like june hoe could have
easily remembered so why not add some
more details and if instead their men is
a here's what i learned in case i've
been prematurely cremated message to his
superiors then it's even more useless
this could just as easily be the notes
to juno's debut novel in progress the
story of a triangle mass gang leader
that gets caught up in a riot resulting
in the accidental murder of his own
brother wait someone get netflix on the
line i've got a movie
morse code i'm not sure which to send
more that his brain turned random
coughing into morse code and roughly
zero point get the [ __ ] out of here
seconds or that he happened to know
morse code enough to translate it this
quickly so i'll just say that this phone
still has 39 battery left somehow
instead what's the point of this design
where you have to randomly walk upstairs
just to walk back down them and why are
there no guardrails i'm seriously
starting to think they don't care about
these people's safety we have a team
well the thing is though
so
i can't join unless she does too so
player 69 can't do anything without his
partner being involved nice i'm good at
everything you know that's true how
could he possibly know what she's saying
is true is this a sexual reference
because i doubt that you setting an
intercourse record or being a fellatio
overachiever is going to come into play
in the next game
one
two
three
four
five counting this slow because you're
waiting for the camera to catch up i
would now like to welcome you all
to the third game
today's game is
tug of war episode takes 40 minutes to
start squid gaming this image is
stunning when it comes to cool visuals
squid game truly killer damn it
the us presidency this bloody crucifix
is a bloody lie unless one of the guards
decided to go over it again with a much
thicker application of people inc okay
when i was young we always like talk war
it's a game i know well
and back then
i would always win get to the strategy
already number one your elevator ride to
the death platform is already over and
you're still here giving your bona fides
the show will now slow down their walk
to the rope as if he could give all
these instructions on the way there but
by the time he's talking about having a
good person in the front they're already
being handcuffed in seriously when is
the speech even happening death isn't
the only thing they cheat in this game
they cheat the timing too i'll count
is it just me or do these cliffhangers
ring hollow when netflix has already
skip credited me to the next episode
before i've even had a chance to get up
and grab a cup of earl grey also squid
game is bold but it isn't kill off 90 of
the main cast in one tug bolt so it's
hard to believe there's more than one
possible outcome to this cliffhanger or
is there stay tuned to the next
thrilling installment of tv sims to find
out
[Music]
that wasn't flying that was falling with
style this is all we get all right now
get mad at them damn days
oh no he died did you forget the rules
seventh rule fights will go on as long
as they have to
i would like to extend to you an
invitation to the pants party excuse me
the
party the pants with the pants party
with pants
brick are you saying that there's a
party in your pants and that i'm invited
that's it
tell us what are you good at i'm the
doctor
i'm a time lord don't breathe or make a
noise
if i hear you breathe
i'll hurt you down and get you like a
fish
what's your name old
[Music]
i'm
man
come on
don't lose your spirit you were meant to
be here tonight this is your time their
time
is done
it's over screw them this
is your time now go out there and take
it